en vérité le gouvernement a saisi
l'occasion comme s'il avait voulu
profiter des circonstances pour élargir
incroyablement
la délinquance possible c'est ainsi que
en fait il interdit désormais le droit
de manifester le droit de se réunir même
dans des époques extrêmement rudes ou
lendemain de la Révolution 1830 au
lendemain des événements de 1934 de
ligue de diffractieuses ou de 1936 au
moment où il y avait des conflits dans
la rue on n'est jamais allé si loin en
vérité le gouvernement fait une loi de
police c'est qu'il n'a pas fait son
devoir ce qui n'a pas vu même assumé sa
responsabilité alors il demande au
députés de l'apprendre à sa place c'est
une mauvaise loi et latin tout le monde
puis personne n'est en sécurité voilà
pourquoi j'ai cru de voir déposer la
question préalable c'est-à-dire demander
à l'Assemblée nationale de votre compte
la loi